q
is for
charge you have a lot of electric charge
i'll use big q q is for
tiny charge which q should i use on the
start of the video then
big q
because i'm going to be talking about
big q okay
uh sorry i need my jumper if i take my
jumper
and rub
a balloon against it you're going to get
charges so if my if i had more hair or
if i could use you as a model we could
see that whether the hair is sticking up
is it sticking up
yeah i can see i feel quite
foolish there are this is an insulator
and i'm rubbing off charges either
positive or negative there's probably
electrons and it goes on to my jumper
and that leaves this neck positive
charge or it's the other way around i
don't know you have to work out these
things so as a result of this if i would
take two of these this one
it wants to be near my jumper did you
see that but if i rub this and put it on
the wall
i'm going to see now whether i've rubbed
it enough the electric charge will
actually hold it there we've got
positive charges in the wall a negative
charge on the balloon or the other way
around
and as a result
you can stick these things on the wall
or not that one didn't do enough charges
and they will attract each other very
via force which is cool called the
coulomb force when i was like my kids
were small i used to do this and put it
on the ceiling just to keep it out of
their way until my wife complained that
it attracted all the dust molecules and
left 30 great mark on the ceiling
this is a pvc rod
and if i rub it this is just kitchen
paper all right i'm doing the same thing
to the insulator as i did before and if
i get some water running out the tap you
make it run so that it comes out as a
little cylinder and you put this near it
can you see that
and it looks as though i'm doing magic
well there's a charges on this which you
can't see normally because it doesn't
have any effect but these charges create
an electric field which radiates around
from here and it's attracting let's say
we've made this positive it's attracting
the negative part of water that is the
oxygen molecules and the oxygen
molecules are attracted towards this and
the protons the hydrogen atoms are
repelled a little bit so you're just
attracting those and if it can get
nearer
it will attract them much more so it
tends to move the water towards the rod
in fact i'm not allowed in some
laboratories because if theoreticians go
near them everything goes wrong there
you go isn't that pretty
ooh
you've never seen that before
i just want to blow bubbles can i just
blow bubbles
so i can blow bubbles and squirt them
with charges oh no that one oh that one
can you see that one this is a van de
graaff generator for kids
and it squirts out charges it's very
high voltage if i now take off
this bit of thin metal
and
blow out the charges it charges up
and then if i throw it in the ack i'll
get it off my fingers now because of the
soap bubbles i get this lovely pattern
which i can blur around the room for the
next 10 minutes and this is charge and
that's charge and so i can push it where
i want there are electrical charges on
that and the electrical charges on that
and they repel each other rather
well just as gravitational forces
attract things to the earth well charges
if they're like charges
as discovered by benjamin franklin they
repel whereas unlike charges opposite
charges attract so in a hydrogen atom oh
dear you get electrical shock as soon as
you touch that i'm not joking when you
have a hydrogen atom there's a proton
which is positively charged an electron
which is negatively charged and they
attract each other and form a bound
state if you had two protons on their
own they would push apart very quickly a
coulomb per second passing you is one
ampere
so when you talk about i've got a three
amp fuse
you're talking about three
coulombs per second passing in front of
you so if you imagine
one coulomb
equals
6 times 10 to the 18
e
18.
so that means if you have one coulomb
there are six times
10 to the 18 electrons all marching past
so a 3 amp fuse has three times that 1.8
times 10 to the 19. it's a huge number
of charges and you don't see them
normally because they're so small by
comparison we know things we normally
see that's why i'm shooting out huge
number of charges charging this thing up
which acts as a capacitor
and then as i put positive charges on
the end of this it repels he did
experiments where he took pith balls
which are you've heard of pith helmets
where they made little balls out of this
insulating material and he managed to
arrange things so that these two pith
balls were charged and then he changed
the separation between them and managed
to measure the force and he showed the
force between them varied inversely as
the square of the separation just like
the force between two objects in gravity
depends inversely on the separation of
the two masses so he was the first
person to actually elucidate the law of
electrostatic repulsion or attraction
depending on the charges
pretty clever guy then
well in the pantheon of physicists he's
way up there
people who discover laws of physics
tend to be regarded as
pioneers and wonderful people some of
them are some of them aren't